I have never heard of this before ever
if it's like a Japanese holy walk
assertion we majored in art stuff so so
I'm imagining edible Legos and I'm
actually really excited wait this
becomes a tentacle oh my god this one's
coca-cola flavor move this go in there
this kind of reminds me of that play-doh
kit where you like make the people's
hair oh yeah you have to have like
nimble fingers for this looks like
Pinterest fail so this is what the
package looks like and this is what our
product looks like
nailed it forget all the best friends I
don't expect there to be so many steps
to making this candy in America it just
comes in the gummy bear shape ooh ice
cream
esque things I'm excited about the fun
kind of looks like the candy world of
wreck-it Ralph
oh it does they're so little these are
so cute this is measuring this thing is
a measuring tool I love it you can
decide for all this I was just gonna
wing it
oh that was like good oh I see oh we're
behind on the times America our toys are
so dumb compared to this
oh we've squeezed it on here that I do
like the little like oh that's awesome
this is the perfect thing for like
having a friend over put the tip oh yeah
this is what Dairy Queen taught me oh I
scream it out yes oh that kind of
phallic it was pretty you ruined
everything
oh wait is it not good it tastes like
wet sands it looks great
mmm tastes like
Oh God the defectors it's no mini
direction I feel like it's just molding
them though right like we don't have
that many options I'm gonna taste like
toothpaste wait where is it orange is
this square which orange oh we want our
little one this one this looks like the
broccoli mrs. Bach we've got to put
water in there right I know I just don't
know how much pink pink goes in the
pineapple thing Baloo is supposed to go
in here yeah because the gray goes no
wait this is the red goes in there oh
you know what I think the blue goes in
there and then the red goes in there wow
they're becoming gelatinous I want this
to look good if this looks bad I'm gonna
cries it out of ohh oh no a little
deformed but that's okay it looks like
snot the whole spectrum of snot I think
we did pretty well I think that we
killed it we crushed it looks like
they're in our defense we don't speak
Japanese and it's really hard if I had
the time set aside I feel like I could
do a really good job this one was a
rough one props to Japan because like if
I was a parent and you're gonna give you
candy at least give them like a candy
that will keep them occupied for like a
half hour that's a great idea